ja wir haben aktuell in deutschland für
viele menschen ein riesiges problem das
sind die dramatischen preissteigerungen
viele menschen können das was zum leben
notwendig ist aktuell nicht mehr
bezahlen heute hat die koalition ein
entlastungspaket beschlossen ja da ist
einiges vernünftiges dabei aber ich sage
im kern ist das ein entlastungspaket
andere länder haben entschlossen
gehandelt und ich sage auf der hand
liegt dass man wirklich bei
grundnahrungsmitteln bei
grundnahrungsmitteln die mehrwertsteuer
senkt der staat hat im vergleich zum
vorjahresquartal 18,8 milliarden mehr
eingenommen das muss den bürgerinnen und
bürgern zurückgegeben werden ich stehe
auch für andere möglichkeiten offen aber
die mehrwertsteuersenkung wäre das
schnellste wenn natürlich eine
staatliche aufsicht da ist die auch
dafür sorgt dass die preise bei den
verbraucherinnen und verbrauchern an wir
haben die situation dass bei dem
entlastungs päckchen rentnerin und
retten dann nur sehr eingeschränkt sehr
sehr eingeschränkt betroffen sind also
viele fallen durch zum beispiel bei den
energiekosten und wir haben eine
situation dass in dieser lage die
kinderarmut steigt hier muss staatlich
entschlossener gehandelt werden das was
jetzt passiert ist ist zu wenig
inflationsrate bei sieben prozent
rentner bekommen kaum etwas ampel ist
gefordert das heutige kann maximalen
stadt gewesen sein
[Applaus]
sie
werden ja eigentlich angesprochen ja
herzlichen dank das ist mir auch gegen
halten dann die meinung zu haben und
auch die gegen die gegnerische meinung
sozusagen von meiner seite zu höheren
grundfreibetrag erhöht aber die mama
pauschbetrag erhöhte pendlerpauschale
erhöht wir werden etwas einführen bei
benzin steuern dass er das reduzieren
direkt eine tankstelle volumen plus die
sozialleistung die wir geben mich
beispielsweise heizkostenzuschuss den
man noch mal verdoppelt haben mir geht
es nicht darum lobby in eine
zusammenarbeit statt und einem punkt
recht das kommt jetzt gerade bei den
menschen in deutschland an und gerade
bei den kleinen und mittleren einkommen
die es schwer haben ich habe das nur auf
gezählt weil das türmt sich insgesamt
auf eine summe von 30 milliarden euro
entlastungspaket das ist tatsächlich
historisch hat zu große zeiten und davor
auch nie gegeben das heißt diese
regierung tut etwas und jetzt sagt
herbert da müsste noch einmal oben drauf
ich habe die uns eine sache vergessen
das darf ich sagen all die dinge die ich
zu steuerlich aufgezählt haben werden
wir rückwirkend zum ersten januar diesen
jahres
auch das hat es noch nicht gegeben herr
barth sagt die mehrwertsteuer da
antworte ich für grundnahrungsmittel
grundnahrungsmittel da antworte ich da
haben wir während der korona pandemie
eine sehr schlechte erfahrung gemacht
sie sagen ja eine vorübergehende
mehrwertsteuersenkung das hat die gruppe
ja schon mal gemacht während corona und
ich habe immer gesagt das ist eine
amazon- corona hilfe steuer gewesen das
hat nämlich den menschen nicht wirklich
was gebracht weil die garantie dass
damit die preise senken die kann der
staat nicht geben wir haben ein
besonderes problem wir reden von
hunderttausenden von produkten in der
sozialen marktwirtschaft wird es der
stadt nicht schaffen das zu monitoren ob
die steuersenkung die hadsch möchte
wirklich dann auch an der ladenkasse
ankommt deswegen ein nein von meiner
seite zu einer vorübergehenden
mehrwertsteuersenkung und im jahr gibt
es im bundestag von mir zu dem was die
gefahr dass die ampel koalition hier
macht also bei einigen maßnahmen die wir
haben wir beschlossen hat bin ich ja
überhaupt nicht dagegen also eeg-umlage
abschaffung jetzt richtig hässlich
vergessen ja ich wollte helfen wo ich
andere sondern war auch loben wenn etwas
lobenswertes da ist nur eins bleibt all
diese maßnahmen sind bei einer inflation
von 7,3 prozent und ich erwähne jetzt
mal zwei andere gruppen die rentnerinnen
und rentner die bekommen eben auf dem
energiesektor nichts nichts die rentner
sind nur sehr eingeschränkt betroffen da
kann man jetzt sagen da hat herr heil
gesagt ja aber wir haben die höchste
rentenerhöhung in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik west ja sie ist niedriger
als die inflationsrate
oder nehmen sie die kinder bei kindern
und das sind ja gerade alleinerziehende
die die wenig haben da kommt von diesem
paket objektiv wenig an und deswegen
sagen ich bei grundnahrungsmitteln
da kann es helfen denn sie haben recht
ansonsten mehrwertsteuersenkung ich habe
das damals auch porsche rabatt da wollen
wir noch weiter in der opposition haben
wir schwer kritisiert genannt da ist ja
etwas dran weil das für die natürlich
viel mehr ist deshalb wirklich
eingeschränkt aber generell meine these
ist wir haben jetzt durch den ukraine
krieg natürlich durch all die dinge die
jetzt mit lieferung zu tun haben vor
shanghai die schiffe usw lieferketten
sind unterbrochen riesenprobleme ich
will das überhaupt nicht kleinreden das
ist auch nicht die verantwortung der
neuen ampel regierung aber diese
explodierenden preise die hatten wir so
noch nicht und das ist nicht das ende
der fahnenstange
deswegen ist das jetzige wirklich nicht
ausreichend insbesondere für diejenigen
mit kleinen einkommen und darum jetzt
die große differenz auszumachen das ist
ein punkt ich sage aber auch wir müssen
mal bei den unternehmen die jetzt
wahnsinnig profit gemacht haben uns
extra profite dann müssen wir vielleicht
auch den mut haben etwas abzuholen wir
müssen auch vielleicht bei denjenigen
die über wahnsinns vermögen verfügen
sagen in dieser situation muss dafür die
für die des monats 21 damals gute idee
befragten einfach mal jemand ich hoffe
ich darf das hier sagen herr doktor
doktor zählte man sie haben ja ein
wahnsinns vermögen also wollen sie jetzt
nicht einfach etwas abgeben herr busch
sagt der staat soll zu ihm kommen und
ein paar millionen abzweigen gesehen
eine million abzweigen könnte und es
passiert nichts dann ja alle hart es ist
ja auch keine neue these das ist ja egal
was auf der welt passiert ihre lösung
stand immer die millionäre die sollen
jetzt bezahlen und damit seien alle
probleme der welt gelöst aber so ist es
halt nicht also wenn sie sagen
mehrwertsteuersenkung da bin ich dafür
ich bin immer für jede steuersenkung
grundsätzlich jeder arzt also da haben
sie mich immer als anhänger aber man
muss ja mal gucken was sind die ursachen
inflation ja sie haben ja ein paar tiger
genannt jetzt aktuell ukraine kriegt man
könnte auch sagen die verfehlte
energiepolitik die weil es über jahre
gehabt haben aber es gibt ein hauptgrund
und das ist die politik der
zentralbanken seit jahren ja dass die
gelddruckmaschinen angeworfen worden
sind dass die zinsen auf null gesenkt
worden sind dass anleihekäufe sind das
ist der eigentliche grund und da können
wir machen was wir wollen das ist so
ähnlich wie wenn sie zum zahnarzt gehen
und sagen wir haben zahnschmerzen gesagt
jetzt immer eine schmerztablette wie
kannst du nehmen aber da sieht man es
eigentlich dass in die zahnschmerz
natürlich nicht weg in dem moment ja und
das und ja vorübergehend und das problem
ist nur dass muss man ehrlicherweise
sagen dass die politik das nicht direkt
beeinflussen kann weil die zentralbanken
sollen unabhängig sein und die
zentralbanken sind aber die hauptursache
also die ezb in europa und die fed in
den vereinigten staaten die die
verantwortliche sind durch ihre politik
für die inflations wege hat auch die
politik leider muss man sagen nur im
beschränkten einfluss grad und ich gebe
dir recht sicher ist der anfang das kann
auch noch schlimmer kommen will man denn
dann immer mehr immer mehr staatliche
hilfen dass das das geht nicht
also ich darf einmal noch mal wieder
sprechen also zunächst mal wenn sie
diese jawohl ich bin dafür dass wir in
dem bereich wo wirklich menschen kaum
das monatsende erreichen etwas tun
müssen und das betrifft inzwischen mehr
dass wir dort auch über maßnahmen
mehrwertsteuersenkung auf
grundnahrungsmittel ist ein punkt
direkte hilfen werden total wichtig und
richtig würde ich präferiere aber ich
will eins noch sagen weil sie sagen
jetzt hilft es immer dieselbe these ich
will mal 1 festhalten in der pandemie im
letzten jahr haben die zehn reichsten
deutschen die zehn reichsten nur die
zehn reichsten einen vermögenszuwachs
von 100 milliarden da sind sie nicht
dabei traurig ich bin auch nicht dabei
auch traurig und weber hat das problem
es geht doch überhaupt nicht darum zu
schaden es ist doch geht doch nicht
darum zu schaden aber nicht den mut
haben wir einen kleinen 201 kleinen
terbahl ist es schadet denjenigen die
wenig haben ich plädiere
wissen sie wenn jemand der jüngste ja
der ist aus deutschland der hat 2,2
milliarden mit 21 jahren da ist im
system etwas schräg einer feuchten stoff
würde hätten also freue mich darüber
nicht weil es dann eine falsche
erbschaftssteuer gibt weil es dann eine
es ist nicht es ist niemandem
vermittelbar wenn sie kinder haben die
am monatsende nicht sagt werden und auf
der anderen seite jemand mit 22
mehrfacher milliardär ist dann ist im
lande etwas faul
also wir müssten mal ein bisschen dort
hier also ein bisschen sortieren von was
reden wir dann reden wir von geld auf
der auf dem sparbuch nein das reden wir
natürlich nicht das ist investiertes
vermögen von dem herbert spricht da sind
maschinen hein das sind anlagen das in
jobs deswegen wird mache ich einen
vorwurf an die linkspartei es gibt ja
auch andere parteien im deutschen
bundestag die immer mal wieder die idee
haben so genannte substanz steuern
einzuführen das wort muss ich mal kurz
in die runde werfen das heißt nicht aus
dem was sich erwirtschafte gebe ich dem
staat richtigerweise was ab sondern aus
dem was ich bereits habe sozusagen was
er per se kein gewinn abwirft die
steuern die herr bartsch vor schlicht
würden auch unternehmen zahlen die in
dem jahr verluste machen die würden
diejenigen zahlen die groß sind
gegebenenfalls auch mittelständler aber
die würden nichts anderes machen als
jobs abbauen müssen denn gerade bei der
erbschaftsteuer und jetzt erheblich
anheben würde ein junger firmenerbe und
es gibt mir gar nicht darum ob ich dem
das gönnen oder nicht aber ich will dass
die jobs erhält das ist doch mein punkt
dass es lohn und brot und arbeit viele
millionen menschen in deutschland gerade
im mittelständischen bereich dhl die
vorschläge dieser substanz steuern die
gehen an die substanz des deutschen
mittelstandes und kosten uns jobs das
heißt dass produziert invite armut ich
war gerade
steckt eine bestimmte vorstellung
dahinter also bei ihnen steckt immer die
vorstellung dahinter der arme der ist
nur arm weil der reiche reiches das
kennen sie ja das gedicht von bert
brecht bestimmt aber mit reicher mann
standen da und sahen sich an und der
arme sagte bleich welchen staaten wärst
du nicht reich und bekenntnissen und das
ist das ist einfach unsinn ja und ich
kann auch erklären warum gucken sie mal
zum beispiel im jahr 2000 da war es doch
so da gab es 500 milliarden auf der welt
heute gibt es fünf mal so viele
milliardäre
gleichzeitig ist die zahl der armen auf
der ganzen welt von 24 prozent im jahr
2000 auf unter zehn prozent gesunken das
heißt wenn diese logik stimmen würde von
dem gedicht von bertolt brecht was auch
ihre logik ist ja da könnte man das ja
gar nicht erklären das ist der grund ihr
kennt sich wachstum reguliert dass es
wachsen dass ich erklären dass er okay
erstmal will ich als nächstes jahr
sprechen weil also dass sie vertreten
die these die linke will die substanz
besteuern und unternehmen kaputt machen
und arbeitslosigkeit also wir sind wir
nicht behämmert also wenn wir dann die
sachen ja wäre diese substanz versteuert
habe ich doch niemals gesagt also auch
bei einer vermögenssteuer im übrigen
gibt es eine private das ist ja übrigens
das problem wird es deshalb hat das
verfassungsgericht das 96 aufgehoben
weil diese trennung etwas schwierig ist
aber darum geht es nicht wir haben in
deutschland sechs millionen geldvermögen
allein das ist ja ein spannender da ist
ja schon mal eine frage ob ihr an und
ich wiederhole noch mal niemand kann mir
erklären übrigens die 2,2 milliarden des
jüngsten milliardär der welt die sind
nicht nur in anlagen dass er einfach
nicht wahr das war also da sage ich ganz
klar wir müssen regeln
der welt können sie doch nachlesen ich
bin ja da ganz der heißt lena übrigens
ist so nett der name und das hilft und
nicht so sonderlich weiter aber das ist
jetzt nicht der punkt ist ich kenne ihn
gar nichts wahrscheinlich netter mensch
wahrscheinlich wird er ganz darum gehen
zu dem fest geht fürs am ende
das ist ja melden sich vor allem
menschen es ist schön dass ich fühle
mich ein beispiel
wissen sie wir haben in deutschland
leider und niemand am tisch wird sagen
dass das gut ist eine steigerung bei der
quote kinderarmut alle sind dagegen ja
ich weiß das sag ich habe mit sich ich
habe also auch dort mit fdp-kollegin
früher an diesem thema da muss was
passieren
kindergrundsicherung was er im
koalitionsvertrag steht wo ich gesagt
habe ich ausdrücklich da ist auch in
diesem haushaltsjahr nicht ein cent ich
bin sehr gespannt ob das kommt warum
passiert nicht da viel schneller etwas
und was diese riesen vermögen betrifft
nochmal ich bin für ausgleich wer
vermögen sich erarbeitet wer etwas
leistet nur zu aber diese wahnsinnigen
das meiste vermögen in deutschland wird
vererbt und nicht erarbeitet doch sagen
kann ich kann ich ihm gleich es gab
neuerlichen untersuchung da ging es
eigentlich ein anderes thema vom dgb
ganz unverdächtig unterliegen sie eigene
strom um den zusammenhang von
persönlichkeitsmerkmalen und millionären
und da haben die zu gleichen stichprobe
gemacht wie viel waren der erben und
wieviel waren da selbst mit leute ja
dann waren einige wo es nicht sagen
konnte wenn man dir ausrechnet waren 79
prozent waren selfmade und 21 prozent
waren haben sie ja mal sein diese studie
die ich auch sogar kenne und das sind
diejenigen die pur geerbt haben
diejenigen die natürlich ein erbe
bekommen und das aussehen sind sofort
selfmade also das ist eine interessante
studie ich habe das gelesen sogar weil
ich mir genau auch diese zahl auf gefahr
meine these und die bei der bleibe ich
auch da haben wir gott sei dank
unterschiedliche sichten ich sage wir
müssen dort für ausgleich sorgen wir
müssen für chancengleichheit bei den
heranwachsenden und deswegen natürlich
kann man die these vertreten also jede
steuern also ist eine zu viel steuer ist
auch die vertrete ich ausdrücklich nicht
der staat hat aufgaben die wir
realisieren muss und eine dieser
aufgaben ist dafür zu sorgen dass jedes
kind sieht seine fähigkeiten und
fertigkeiten entwickeln kann die chancen
bekommt und dazu gehört auch eine
angemessene besteuerung in deutschland
wird ordentlich besteuert wir sind ja
jetzt schon ehrlich gesagt jetzt kann
man ja auch europäischen vergleich sind
höchst euer land einer ist noch folgen
ich finde ist es denn das ziel das ist
jetzt die letzte frage zu den thesen die
möchte ich gerne ein händler stellt ist
es denn dass ihr es jetzt an auch
belgien überholen und der spitzenmann
wer es wäre eine katastrophe wenn ich
eine rote linie für meine partei auch
bei dieser koalition über die wieder
gleichen auch reden gab mich zu sagen es
gab keine steuererhöhungen weitere
kärnten gegenteil wir müssen entlastung
war ein paar machen wir einsatz bitte
vor schenkten mich zu der frage na ja
das investierte vermögen das will ich
als linker ja schon mir geht es um das
große geld vermögen also um die dagobert
duck und seinen tresor wie ist das in
wahrheit was würde denn in dem moment
passieren das geldvermögen das ist
flexibel das wandert ins ausland aber
der arme investierte untersagt mit
anführungszeichen der investierte
unternehmer der jobs geschaffen hat der
würde von der steuer von herrn bartsch
getroffen der müsste gegebenenfalls
verkaufen oder würde jobs abbauen
deswegen sage ich das klingt gut aber
ist in weiter das gegenteil von robin
hood warum hat eigentlich die fdp ein
konzept bei der erbschaftsteuer dass
durch die bank drei prozent erhoben
werden sollen das war also sie sie
sprechen auf alte dinge an wenn sie ins
wahlprogramm reinschaut dann sehen sie
dass wir bei der erbschaftsteuer sagen
es muss vernünftige chance möglichkeiten
geben weil da habe ich nichts dagegen
die unterschiede natürlich halten bin
ich immer dafür frei und teilnehmer die
unternehmen das nach über die ich gerade
sprach weil wir die nicht belasten
wollen